just take a private jet come out to
terran tactical squeeze off some rounds
dude it's a it's a blast we do Ted we we
do absolutely no but if you guys are
ever in Vegas man you go to my house I
live in Vegas yeah okay Joe that's not
you don't have to say it like that don't
it's so obnoxious well how much is your
mortgage I don't [ __ ] know dude it's
neither do i cuz I don't have one
they're all pedo all right dude all
right yeah I know we came at me well no
you did you're like I asked you where if
you lived in Vegas yeah I live in me all
right fine the ridges is it a big house
yeah that's huge
okay dude how's your view um no but I'm
addicted we should come shooting with me
I'm gonna go I'm going there are three
you I come just come just come if you
guys are an hour in Vegas we're not your
average is when you listen to me God
yeah I will give you the code to my
house and you can stay there I don't
have to I live in the ridges it's the
most where the elite said all right dude
man Vegas you're in the desert yeah it's
a second house to be fair Oh [ __ ]
burn raaaah
wait where do you live here ah studio
right Studio City do you like it there I
love it
what a great area it's just beautiful I
love you I love you I swear
yes kind of a real live trend it's got a
basketball court are we are we are all
that we caught the you've been bragging
in me did you close yourself you go you
said that's worthy do that I did not say
any of that
those were that was all in fun and you
said you came at me for no and then you
said to me you go dead you go you looked
at me I don't want to spend rumors but
Joe look man you would you say that
that's what I heard I did not say that
and you said this to you go that would
be cool would that be cool no that's not
cool I'll be on my porch with some
lemonade and I'll let you stand next to
me
yeah out of all the other white ones out
there what the [ __ ] yeah come over your
house why do yeah you'll be my house why
do one of my duties you spit in my
lemonade here's your lemonade that's
right I get over here Kallen I keep real
quiet
I think Zach Allen mr. Callen mr. Callen
damn you got an old-school plantation
yeah yeah you also said that you favor
keeping us locked down for a year I
don't know me no I didn't know hey you
got a what do you have a Gucci
windbreaker huh okay man this and you
now it needs to stop but that out now it
needs a stop you're dead serious man
look what what are your shoes a coin
purse no dude they're not a cool store
you sort coins in there hey is that a
satchel you've had that on grains Oh you
ride your horse and then you feed your
horse with you you take your shoe up
there's grain zero say that huh these
are golden for you you can put water in
there you drink water oh that yeah
there'll is that a camel's nutsack
yeah they double as a [ __ ] water
bladder sure hey can I get a pair of
Converse that look like a stump
from a tree dude these are golden goose
be cool they're moss green be cool
they're better than what you usually
wears
I'll give them no I will say this you I
love you know I love the way you think
okay yeah I love your thoughts man if
your thoughts were gesture outfits
huh all right does it make sense I don't
have you bent your basketball fan and
you've been watching the last dance
the documentary oh my god it's just it's
it's such a brilliant documentary and
I'm glad they waited 20 years to bring
it out right it's been 20 years right
they took
98 98 and I'm glad they did that because
uh it was getting to the point where
people forgot how great that era was the
younger generation for they they really
because my argument with my son is just
like non-stop and it's like LeBron er
well yeah and don't get me wrong I love
LeBron but it's a completely different
game like you know when when Michael was
playing it it was a completely I mean
they changed the rules for Michael they
beat the [ __ ] out of Michael they beat
the [ __ ] out of each other
yeah like let's not forget Isiah Thomas
went Karl Malone elbowed him to the eye
and he still played with stitches in his
head and John Stockton he used to get
beat up all the time the game rougher
mph is more physical no no it's more
physical man now my glorying you know
it's more whole later there's a lot of
you know there's a lot it was really
full contact back then I mean watch the
documentary you can see it there much
thicker now though right there the mo no
alright can you not participate in this
particular conversation you really
stupid comment I anyway we know why it
off is microwave talk to the fighter and
shut the kid up no I want to talk sports
guys hold on dude please stop
yeah what's interesting is there's
arguments for both sides because one guy
like who they have on they had on
Shaquille O'Neal yeah on first take this
morning yeah there you go how many
points would Jordan average right now in
the NBA and he goes 4500 in the game
they're playing 45 kids now it's
physical yeah but the it's not physical
at all it's not fit but it's not not the
way they played back there but I'll say
this I mean we can name all the great
players from the 90s but the level of
talent now is way deeper than they way
deep
you think John Paxton would have played
right now
ya know it'd be tough oh man yeah he
would have I don't think I can shoot his
ass but now our off but turned my record
where now yeah I beat John Paxson call
throat bulb
yeah but they you remember to Joe's the
the Europeans they weren't involved
really back then now there's such a
worldwide game because that Olympic team
thank you Michael yeah yeah thank you
Michael
yeah but the love of competitions little
I think it's they're better players oh
yeah what happened yeah one other form
one to twelve not saying starting five
yeah I want to talk but but now you can
truly see just how great Michael Jordan
was I know kids forgot y'all [ __ ]
forgot not now my son he's been watching
and he's like you're right dad this is
this is amazing he's amazing
Artie Lange had the greatest description
of Michael Jordan he goes if he had been
on the Titanic it wouldn't a sunk he
would have been plugging holes and
[ __ ] running back I think I think in
the pod I think in the pot after that
and this is just some direction yeah
forty seconds of complete sir okay
slowly zoom into its finest right I'm
trying to be part of the conference and
they said I don't think it doesn't even
make sense the holes yes what is he the
fastest man on earth
I just mean he's got will too you know
we don't know stupid every time your son
I've said it four times I don't that's a
fight just whatever Jordy says that if I
know I wanted him to be like that's a
great metaphor and though he hated who
you are though who I know who you are
you're the guy like like at ninety eight
you were well forty like in 98 when you
were forty no you're a huge Jordan fan
yes you were yes and and then slowly it
became this thing where you wanted to be
against the popular right because it's
fun for Brian well I seen Gabe I just
didn't grow up now all of a sudden he
went from being a huge fan in 98 to like
who's the Michael Jordan guy now happen
already laying out reference for the
Michael Jordan all right
full name all right they see your black
dad that's not how I talk man you
playing baseball that's Michael Jordan
all this [ __ ] is intact
alright listen you do good job take it
with you thanks care to you
Joe I'm not scared of you Joe take it
easy let me explain something let me at
least warn Tina wait a bunch a lot but
Joe hey you know what he always be is
when I asked like a spider like Grogan
I'm like hey have you guys seen that the
last dance documented I just haven't had
time
hey what do you been doing what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm right you know bright
then I finished ozark night yeah yeah
yeah here's the thing here's the thing
about sports with me which is very sad I
didn't grow up in this country I came
here around 14 now when I came here
Yugoslavia
we all got different parts of the world
yeah when I came here I wanted to
include it like I do now yeah so guys
that talk sports and I would I didn't
want to hold you in high school and that
in no sports so I think you're a liar no
no I really do in the world when you
were in high school
Jordan in any part of the world yeah was
Michael Jordan it was more in college
but yeah I mean 89 when I graduated
college community whatever he was big
news big deal though he was it was
Michael Jordan the most famous damn
earth him a Michael J well Michael
Jackson yeah it was Michael Jackson
Michael Jordan but Michael Jordan really
brought like the whole world it was
crazy it was nuts I know you saw in the
documentary it was it crazy I felt bad
for him I felt bad for all like you know
you can't relax when the reason he said
he remember when he said I hate it like
I'm ready to go now I'm done that's
crazy
cuz no one really understands that right
we could never understand that so to
walk out and they're already waiting
because they actually maybe Kevin Hart
no no not now you're talking about no
I'm saying I'm saying where you go to
restaurant people out front waiting
there's always some of that with guys
like Seinfeld and heart like Marilyn
old-school ones yeah what title was
really famous I remember I was at a
restaurant and there was and I'm not
exaggerating it happens to Adam Sandler
- there Adam there were others that
there are 100 200 people we are and they
were following him as he was walking
with Mario Mario - ah yes yes I'm saying
I still think Adam has that pool - I've
been at movies yes he does he did here
here with Adam yeah not one person stop
oh really oh really you're at the malibu
chili cook-off I mean he don't get me
wrong I hate did her up maybe because
you were next door you might be right
yeah might be maybe cuz you were next
well we were when we were in I was at
the Malibu chili cook-off that chili
thing he was trying to walk around his
family all the Chili's laundry of a
hundred hold on no we can't move forward
after that the famous I hope you don't
go the Mel Malibu chick completely and
go they were like this you know the
chili what well you had to [ __ ] I
figured you had money no don't do that
don't train called yourself an elite I
did not show you that and you said the
common cattle he was it my audience but
be real Adam suddenly got swamped I
really only got swamped dude like a
hundred people and he and I mean they
wouldn't leave alone he's with his kids
he this and this is six or seven years
ago when Tim Tebow's the high of his
career we weren't uh I guess it was
super all weekend we went to a
restaurant wait to leave the restaurant
yeah there were so many people outside
trying to yeah I mean I've never seen
anything like in my life I'm talking
hundreds of people it's pushing against
the glass door and they're like Tim we
hate to do this we know you're in the
middle of dinner we have to get the back
man Wow he had to leave he couldn't go
anywhere Wow that stuff is exhausting
now if you're Jordan that's Monday
through Sunday 24th yeah he can't get
coffee yeah did Tom Cruise talked about
that - a friend of mine Tom Cruise said
every time he comes out of his [ __ ]
but he's good now he had to leave he
didn't live in LA but more that's for 20
years in Los Angeles he had to he would
come out of his gate and there were
people that would wait there
there was always always about 30 40
paparazzi who and they was all about -
yeah every single [ __ ] day when he
would when he would travel
so weird when I when he got into his car
it was at this party and he got into his
SUV he had curtains there was intented
he had maybe like curtains I was a
actually an SUV I remember I don't know
man that kind of that kind of [ __ ] is
that's gotta suck where they have they
also have fake houses they have a house
that they go into I would and then they
go really another house no way yes
yeah I'm Cruz had a fake house where
he'd have meetings and take people to we
have a friend who was there yeah and she
was like eh where do I get the the the
soda and he's all uh you uh you go to my
town I like you go yeah you go to the
right and she'll I went to the right it
was like the workout room yeah you just
didn't know it's nice out no but he
doesn't use like that's great you take
it to light I don't just find it you
know that's when I met when I not met
but when Michael Jackson was in the mall
the forum shopping mall this is like
1991 she's 1990 yet 91 so he was wearing
that red remember that red military
shirt with the yeah well those things
called up here
tassels yeah those things he passed yeah
they were on top of his shoulder it was
like a uniform we had the black fedora
like that a little long kid with him
wearing the same outfit I swear to God
and they were both wearing face masks
ovid right Lenny woman he did her face
mask yeah they both had surgical masks
on and so I'm working at the forum this
is when it was only one wing right it's
not the big forum shopping mall that is
now it was just one wing and it was so
famous because it was the first like
high-end mall in in Vegas and uh so I
worked there I worked there so I'm
standing out front of the store I was a
greeter right and uh and everyone was
like and well it's just like you can
feel the rumbling right and there's this
this thing where the the the the statue
start talking and it's a show and
Michael Wanda watch and he was watching
it from the light where the lights shine
down on it so he's up in the top of the
dome everyone is looking at his glasses
because you can see his glasses looking
down at the the thing and we'll all look
at but no one's looking at the show the
word got around in the mall that he's
there and then somehow I've Corwin knew
that
with him the light Luis when the show is
done he came down [ __ ] pandemonium you
know that she you see in the videos
where it's just [ __ ] chaos and
they're surrounding with security guards
and they're walking it's exactly what
happened [ __ ] and I got his autograph
did you yeah really yeah and I remember
the girl that had a poster this [ __ ]
and I know you know who you are
she had a poster it wasn't her poster
she took a poster for what I worked at
this store called Afghans like a shoe
store and it was like the two-for-one
poster here I mean or whatever it like
she took the poster down cuz she want
him to sign the back of it get it so she
had a pan and I go give me something
give me something give me half like
[ __ ] it's that big give me another e
hurry and she went and ripped the
[ __ ] corner
oh yes corners so the signatures like
this big little is and she had a [ __ ]
poster I go [ __ ] did he sign remember I
ripped away [ __ ] well you think he's
gonna [ __ ] tag it he's a unicorn the
way she did it she was she panicked she
paid me did he sign hers yeah he started
hers and then uh and then he signed my
might and is it really it's really cool
look she'll have it yeah alright here's
the thing it went to there my
ex-girlfriend she's got it we're still
friends I'll tell her to get in the
picture just just brain but also giving
but it's the cozy it's a corner piece
and I had it framed and matted and all
that there's what the Dangerous album
came out it was items go craziest [ __ ]
I've never seen and he was shaking he
component to Sue's he was so scared he
might be very hip like he's jumping on
top of everybody what was he more famous
than Michael Jordan
I mean internal he still is you say like
what Muhammad Ali said one time oh I
don't know oh that's that's okay nah he
is he is here's the thing little boy
stuff [ __ ] him have you ever looked
into that though I did look into it let
me tell you what Michael Jackson did
alright because Michael Jordan is huge
but I'm friends with Jon Lovitz right
donut shop and he took me on the road
when I first got to LA
took me on the road for about a year and
a half I used to open for him and he
said he's best friends with Miko uh uh
who's that little monkey that Michael
Jackson monkey the funny [ __ ] I've ever
yes he's best friends with Michael short
of Michael Jackson's monkey Jones I
don't see how carts I'll do that jump
Macau he still sees them all the time
eco likes it when I do that
no Brando Miko Brando Oh Harlan's son
and that was Michael Jackson's best
friend Miko and he was on that bad tour
he was on that bad tour old was the kid
uh there's Biko right there that's him
nicest guy in the world
yeah and that's Jon Lovitz his best
friend and uh yeah it's like a tan John
Lowe they always have yeah and they
always have Hawaii shirts John is a
great guy amazing funny by the way we
get those white shirts there's a
specific store in Hawaii where you have
to go and get that it's the only place
he'll get those Hawaiian shirts and
Rando son that's Marlon Brando Sumiko
yeah he's probably tuition I don't know
is he full but I got some stories about
me command so sired a lot of kids there
what hey Brando lived in Tahiti for a
long time Oh got 11 children though I do
it how many different baby mama probably
I left a lot Miko super super cool man
and uh he told me he's the one that put
the fire out on Michaels head what yeah
when Michael you'll see footage of when
Michael's head was on fire yeah in from
the Pepsi commercial and you'll see a
guy I stick a coat on his head and plan
out how do I was weak how'd he get so
close with Michael Jackie was his big
Marlin is Michaels Idol that's why we
wanted that know yeah like would you
remember that song he did I forgot the
name of that song with Chris Tucker in
it Marlon Brando was in it Emiko was in
it as well yeah that yeah me go put the
wire out on his head that fire was
intense by the way that's when he got
addicted to the drugs
Oh was it fireworks uh no yeah it blew
up on stage right it's a serious burn
yeah it was
and no one knew really how bad it was
but Pepsi right and that's what he got
addicted to pain medicine Wow
but Mika was saying that tour was the
most you'll never see a tour like that
ever again
there's like seven it was like seven
rigs it was like he Michael only
performed on the weekend so it's like he
did seven Wimbley stadiums
she sold out seven by himself
yeah the act is like a famous band
opening a forum so you can sell Rolling
Stones it was Michael Jackson I don't
think I don't think you you can get that
level of stardom now it'll never ever
have national yes to me [ __ ] one has
they're following their groove
who's who is like that though I mean
who's like who can someone man what the
hell out Wembley Stadium no one it's
either gotta be a festival or 2x maybe
you two maybe maybe you - no I don't
know I think you two still has it though
I think they still got that power
Drake's pretty up there I think Whibley
how many does it hold can you pull that
up cuz that's that's uh that's a rugby
field
that's where fights and sells it out
Joshua feitshans has almost always fight
sir
wait is that nine thousand seated or
90,000 with the fastest eating on the
field you you sell 60,000 seats down to
you there's my camera question please
don't make me angry
good that's a good special by the way
that was my first one all right man I'm
pretty sure yeah Joshua that's where
he'd fight that sells that up okay dad
he sells out Wimbley mm-hmm seven times
no uh check the lights he's had but he's
making like you know forty million a
fight he's selling that [ __ ] out he
said oh my for big fight fight let's go
there I think he fought that's amazing
this show where they fought Jen it's
[ __ ] right there against let's go hold
on Wembley stadium Povetkin he fought
there what was it what was the capacity
stadium Klitschko he fought there Oh -
arena arena Oh - arena
90 times but tell me why yeah we readers
arenas a half the size of the stadium
okay but what about rose rose bulls are
a hundred thousand Rose Bowl no the
biggest is Michigan I think that's the
big house is a hundred I think kick
about that that's clear selling out
non-stop I mean non-stop but it's just
crazy because you know for expenses and
and you know you you you play seven
shows at Wembley you try and knock them
all out in the same week you know I mean
for to bring your costs down
Costas through the roof you're not on
this look at that cancer yeah the ten
artists who sold out ed sheeran well
he's the number one selling are to see
that sells Beyonce yeah
is that Wimbley yeah okay but we're also
forgetting seven times the same we're
not one time in seven time right thing
right action and you got to remember
World Tour still do that in every city
yes yes an incredible run of sold-out
shows that Wembley at you a run of shows
okay you I need to know the news how
hold up appetizing oh yeah those guys
hey those guys yeah she and type in how
many times did Ed Sheeran sell it when
my I forgot about Taylor Swift me guys
at Sharon's the number what you know he
passed Beyonce for most successful tour
I love Ed Church HS did he really have
to go social media cos people were mean
to him or sold out nice or oh okay
that's amazing although you know you
have to understand also the these guys
have the advantage of the internet they
have the advantage of code point you
know that's another had to rely on
traditional Michael Jack no I mean
Michael you do one more time and I'm
gonna do an RD Laing reference yes okay
alright man take it easy
you've been you've coming down hard on
me right now yeah and you're an elite
yeah all right now Eminem
yes he played out but this who shows for
two shows yeah now you can reach so
Taylor Swift can reach so many people at
the Clio [ __ ] the other aspect of that
is think how many how your people can go
to any time there's so many more yeah
artists out there yeah you have so much
more access to artists and social media
and content so to
called out during idle shady yeah that's
that's the other thing yeah Michael
Jackson was literally grass root roots
word-of-mouth types sellout sellout well
you know who still like that they didn't
have that he didn't have the internet to
sell tickets
because I had tickets to the bag concert
and I had to go to Bon marché were
Ticketmaster outlet was inside the
customer service area yeah yeah like it
wait a mission to buy ticket but it was
an event because who else who had to
tell that was an event yeah
so you actually had to go buy the
tickets yeah I had to go buy remember
that you could use it all you could call
on the phone and then you had to go pick
up your ticket people would stand in
line all night outside right now right
now no social media doesn't post
anything Dave Chappelle yep yep so not
radio radio what Radio City Music Hall
17 times that's beautiful you know how
many announcements yeah that's even now
big there's no announcements his tours
with Rogen already sold out they're also
all those stadiums or ears are sold out
beautiful already Michael that is so
beautiful you don't know if they're
gonna do them but that's amazing well
Smith pretty big rock but the rock can't
really sell out well I like the rock but
your batteries I like the rock way
better be the wrong wasn't all staring
enough
he's on every [ __ ] drug look at his
face he's motivating no matter what I
love Will Smith yeah I love what makes
the rock or Will Smith I don't know how
many what have you hey know anybody who
hates the rock or Will Smith okay that's
a great question I dice I love that
question anyone that hates Will Smith or
the rock and suck my dick or pizza can
go [ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself yes anyone that
says I don't like pizza or I have this
one god I hope you get Kovan yeah I hope
you really get a second you'd be fine I
hope you do and I hope that if you're -
I'm Laura Quinn or whatever the [ __ ]
it's called
I hope that that we run out yeah I hope
we run out and I want to get it in the
survival eights 98.9
still there's give me a few days over
you're gonna be scared yeah you probably
have to wear masks to stay inside the
survival rate is 98 not right into so
covert but we may as well for a sec I
will Rogen the polyester with Rogen's
there now you're pretty hard the paint
on it okay
cuz cuz
my blue and say people still wanna Ilana
I've bought two Tesla's from ela who is
that I love you
Rihanna I love you guys town are you
doing that he couldn't reach you were
you pretending that you know she's from
Trinidad stream that - she was made a
billionaire
she should Saudi I think you Saudi
Prince she really and then he got bored
was like where's these toilet moves ass
did she get her what she got her boobies
done I hope not no fun she's amazing no
she got picker yes yeah a lot thicker I
think I think we live in a time now
where people are realizing that thicker
women are hot I think they are always
half well thicker but not obese yeah
yeah yeah like people are given Adel
[ __ ] for losing weight you know that
people are hating on of course you know
who are hating on her the fat girls how
can you do this to us used to be a
representative because she got healthy
you've had cards yeah cuz she stopped
putting chocolate on her vegetables yeah
because she's not drinking ranch
go [ __ ] yourself [ __ ] yourself hope your
heart stops yeah you were getting mad at
her it's like oh my bad my bad
here's the thing man I don't care I
don't care she's big or small the voice
is ridiculous it's the same ring oh
because I think that weight kind of
she's amazing she's understand why she
was so big right like when she blew up
with that song and then I saw her sing
it and I was like holy [ __ ] what's a
[ __ ] talking about fame is when you're
really famous like Amy Winehouse but you
have a drug problem
yeah not sure of that and then you have
an addiction yeah yeah hide that a
dictionary stay inside and it feeds the
addiction yeah she had a mental health
an actual mental health everyone else or
her dad yeah that's crazy this guy who
rock journalist who'd spent a lot of
time because I think she they found her
at the station before she was that she
was at a gas station
she was talking and walking oh that's
not true no no you guys see the
documentary you guys see the guy I did
see I did hear she don't know that's not
what happened at all
no she she was going to rehab she got
clean and her dad's like we need get you
back on the road everybody our team went
this ain't smart no I remember that she
make her go on she comes and that's
where she was I know what I'm saying
that was actually diving her flat yes
what they didn't capture though is that
she had mental illness to shoot having
so she would have incidents of psychosis
so even though she wasn't on drugs she
became she was becoming progressively
more delusional she's doing things are
walking in a circle and and and the rock
journalist said I think that she I think
what we're dealing here with here is
more than drugs I think what we're
dealing with here as somebody who has
mental illness as well and that was I
think when you have mental illness or
you have an addiction and then you're
famous on top of it yes it has to be a
night yes yeah yes this brings me to my
next question I'm not trying to be funny
but when someone is that like genius
like cuz she was a genius yeah and uh I
feel like when they're at that level
they're tapping into a part of their
brain that no one else taps into like we
don't happen like I'm Musk like Elon or
just any of those people that are just
like genius I feel like there's the
schizophrenic or some type of mental
relate to anybody on earth or they can't
get your maybe it's just overwhelming
maybe their brain is working they're
just well I could slow this down that's
that's what Ilana he goes it's almost
like it's a bit of a curse because his
brain doesn't shut down and he look at
some some some people go oh they'll look
at a car a beautiful car or something in
nature and his brains constantly
breaking it down he's like just turn the
[ __ ] off yeah let me enjoy this and he
can't turn off by the way he'll on don't
turn it off
Yeah right so everything that man does I
support Elon 100 and I've been a big
support any twenty day one I bought
everything that that man has put out get
ready to put the the the whatever the
the solar thing into my house the guy is
just such an amazing [ __ ] genius he's
modern-day genius I'm insane for it for
him if whoever he talks to except for a
few handful of people it's like us
talking to four-year-olds all the time
that's a doll everything died they kill
is that good is that good for you okay
little buddy's like but a lot of
geniuses it depends I mean like the
Beatles were pretty sane for most of
them I mean you know the a lot of great
geniuses until you see John Lennon let
his [ __ ] girl with the cowbell in the
[ __ ] that's the crazy though take on
that bring up Bill Pearl it's so good
yeah talking about when John Lennon when
when Chuck Berry and John Lennon are
singing yeah Yoko Ono detention and the
way bills workshop live performance it's
in England live for father can hear is
how bill assumes this is watch this this
is the top one Hungarian titles are
sweet knows yeah that's it that's it as
much as people talk about the Beatles
and how great their music is was
whatever you want to say I totally agree
with them I think that the greatest band
of all time but I have to be honest with
you John Lennon and Paul McCartney
redefined
pussy-whipped you have to watch this
[ __ ] video it's John Lennon is
singing with Chuck Berry Chuck Berry is
probably one of the main reasons why
John Lennon Lennon ever picked up a
guitar so now he's on TV he gets to play
with his idol they're playing Chuck
Berry's hit Memphis okay
John Lennon's got Yoko in his [ __ ]
band they're in the middle of singing
this song on tone and they killing it
it's going great
Yoko's playing some stupid [ __ ] drum
even though [ __ ] talent whatsoever
he's putting her in the [ __ ] band
just shall show shut the [ __ ] up and
stop nagging us because he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] to tell her that she has no talent
all right the only reason why you're
here Yoko's cuz just sucking my dick all
right no you can't play the bongos but
anyway he's up there playing the bongos
right so John Lennon Chuck Berry two of
the Great's of all time harmonizing
singing this hit from the night this is
Korea right here what this moments about
and Yoko in the middle of it can't
handle that she's not getting any shine
she takes the [ __ ] microphone out of
the stand stops playing the bongo and as
this
and you know go go johnny go whatever
she picks up the mic and I swear to God
goes why do you yours and he's that's
[ __ ] brilliant and psycho but he's in
love with her so you can't [ __ ] say
anything and you're just sitting there
waiting for the [ __ ] lightning bolt
hit your friend and he realizes that
he's dating a psycho [ __ ] Chuck before
he had that look good exaggeration
that's what the [ __ ] she did Chuck
Berry's like what the [ __ ] it's kind of
like John that's your woman get her in
line and John Lennon does not even
[ __ ] he doesn't even blink he just he
just keeps playing and then she does it
again later on in that song and then you
look at all the other musicians and they
just keep playing the song like Yoko
isn't even [ __ ] there and I actually
get infuriated when I watch this video
right it's so funny that moment and when
he goddammit he's so right
ah so funny she is a master but I can't
believe they let that happen
you know I assume he'd be Chuck Berry
bag dude what the [ __ ] you know she
can't come onstage with us she broke up
the Beatles I said they always set up a
100 percent like an [ __ ] it was even
hot oh there's oh there's a picture of
them uh naked right and it's just like
bring out up
she's just even our kids are like oh god
she's just
god dammit long stick they may say that
on the regular she's a compiled [ __ ]
well I don't even know that existed sure
does why the great John Lennon that's a
yeah that's a hell of a bush a good one
where that shows their ass oh come on
just has a flat ass I just not what are
you doing John
what are you doing doing this obviously
he's doing squats now she's not
he's got a nice ass harasses that he's
got her ass and she's got it they should
slip that is Jesus Christ she's sitting
forward she's just that she's mr.
Brezhnev he is mr. burns eyes you know
the thing is bird - found her way to the
beatles have the greatest one of the
greatest songwriter of all time and how
about he just a shot man shot hey what's
going on over here
Jesus what I didn't even know these
exist I just do the one where he was in
the fetal position on top right about
this takes a little heart got a cigar on
his lap or something what is that that's
dig I thought it was a cigar and he was
putting dishes out I hope our ever nope
nope he's got a bunch of guys it's a
there's a blunt quality to it he's still
way more attractive than her straight
man yes he is necklace I would way
rather make out with his anyone notice
the necklace she's heard he's the worst
she's Thor's she yeah she ruled the baby
in a lot of ways you imagine if I was
dating some crazy chick and you know I
were getting to a show yo yo hey dude
we're just gonna give Mary five minutes
to open this thing up yeah what the [ __ ]
are you doing my worden I worked in
Vegas and and you know Cirque de Soleil
every time they open up a hotel circus
lay does a show and mirages got a hold
of the Beatles right and I remember
they're selling to because I was selling
tickets at the time and they were like
yeah and Yoko Ono approved of the show
and I'm like who gives a [ __ ] yeah what
does she know who cares
does that give it a signature that make
it an approved
won't you tell me Paul McCartney
approves it I feel much yeah tell me
Ringo Starr at least don't go Yoko said
it's thumbs up you don't have our scene
when what's-his-name the the James
Gordon takes Paul McCartney to Liverpool
where they're from and they go to where
they started all that bar started a
little bar oh that's cool no one note
this it's crowded so the regular Tuesday
afternoon and Palmer get in they go we
have special guests and you know British
people like what the [ __ ] yeah and then
the if they open the gate like the gate
to behind the bar
and Paul McCartney dude I get chills
dude oh yeah they're like losing dirt
yet that's amazing yeah that's somebody
we gotta see before here you know before
that time comes and I hate to say it
that's fine but you got it you got to
see we you have to see Paul you have to
you got to see those songs really his
voice am i exactly the same and he's
just and I hope he I hope he does a tour
and uh III see those Beatles song
sublime James Gordon said he's been
around like like you know I'll see with
the what they do with this show he's
been around tons of famous people he
said he has never experienced anything
like being Liverpool with Paul McCartney
they went to his old house and he's like
all this is where me and John did this
he's got an instrument playing he was
right in this cornice where we wrote
some famous Wow he's come out there damn
it it's not dude I'd love to see I'm
James Corden start singing with him it's
great has James Corden sing yeah
yeah didn't you know that that's why I
show so big he and sinks it I didn't
know that he could say wow I gotta watch
that show rock star care here we go
again
did you hear did you hear Brian there's
breath I gotta see that it's like your
little digs bro with the shoes the
Michael Jordan guy I'm sorry I'm not an
elite Oh Jorgie James Corbett all right
dude yeah educate educate yourself no
I'll give it a look look I'll get a look
I got see kitty can he see it's the
hottest segment bring him up let me hear
him saying [ __ ] you come on you know he
can see I've been on unnecessary
lockdown of really famous because he's a
Broadway guy using Book of Mormon oh
[ __ ] and Moon Moon
the CBS moon what's name you know I'm
talking about
whoo lighting with Bruce Willis guy he
got outed because the me to movement
moon lever come on let's move it let's
move miss it's almost like well that
guy's gonna be a big thing this guy was
like you have any interests being a host
and that's how yet his start yeah James
can sing his ass
any particular one when I play Adele
literally hung anyone he hangs with all
of them yeah that's why they do it
Oh bah he's getting towed by the way
he's not really driving paid to spoil it
for you can sing like he's a Broadway
guy okay stop right there
I'm telling you Adele kissing her
that was amazing right oh you go to the
pit without even paying because you know
peopIe like you know Jesus oh let me see
you hit it I got to start watching this
huh Joe let me come on I think you've
already had these let me come over
you're just you're pretending no you're
pretending we'll only be able to play
the audio we can't do the idea I play
this that's right she could sing her
asses if you want to see a documentary
watch her hills oh she's got a good one
talks about her beef with Christina
Aguilera what a great concept what a
great guy yeah so big what you going
through this yeah taking my sing more
serious thing now you just gotta educate
yourself on like the world yeah yeah why
are you looking at me with these are
these you cutting your eyes at me air
jordans which number though probably the
Aviators you're a really good actor
thank you buddy I've always said that
about you have I not yeah I've always
said you're a great actor I like when he
gets off stage I'm like you're a great
actor I tried though it's understand of
state you're great at when you [ __ ]
you read those lines good on No I
thought you were coming he always goes
to the club with like a script soften me
up and then you [ __ ] you give it
maybe have that guy huh Brian have they
given you any timeline when you start
shooting in September I assume yes I
think in actually August now I want to
ask you on air if you're coming to
Houston and doing stand-up with me at
the improv may 29th
although loaded up may 13th at Texas at
Texas Open is you're going to come to
Texas you and J shop you want to go
there you're gonna co-headline with me
yeah I'll go with it you will I'll go
with you so Brennan and I will be at the
Houston improv oh that's beautiful
great club and Jo koy might come and do
ten minutes we never know either way
you'll do what I say but we're gonna be
at the Houston improv may 29th 30th 31st
yeah I'll tell you what's nuts is when I
open up for Jo yeah I'll be at the
Verizon Center that were James Harden
plays yeah oh okay
don't you have that [ __ ] lost look
that's annoying it's just what's my
camera all right dude hey Joe Sugarland
it's on the outskirts of Houston Hey Joe
how this you just postponed all your
dates like yeah Radio City this it's so
hard for you large eyes though for real
because you guys have to we'll do the
last it's hard I don't mean right now
but it's hard for you guys because
arenas and stadiums are gonna be the
last thing to come back so they're hard
to project insurance at you it's
insurance if that's the biggest and
there's only assume that we're guard in
October yeah supposed to be May 4 Radio
City I also had Rose Garden in Portland
Tyler's other it just sucks man but it's
gonna you mean when you got in into to
place those you know those buildings
those arenas it's hard to find we can
totally I'm sure they're gonna honor
what we did we were able to do it cuz we
jumped on it sounds like you're crying
and everything's gonna be fine I hope so
okay that's great Wow went from a friend
s hole real quick Wow
I thought we had a thing we honor I
thought we had a thing where we do this
I know I know every time the show starts
you okay we got that thing right where
we're gonna I apologize yeah here I'll
call it the fighter I apologize I Paul
the K is already there I know I'm just
saying you're gonna be fine though you
know you'll be fine those things yeah I
know
but that's not how I wanted this to go
no one did man now take it easy I think
James arm feels he can even play that
right now yeah that's true although
they're opening up so they're at
practice and I love people still
complaining well no but the worry is
what when do you think have you talked
to anybody of when first an act as big
as you have they talked about this
because they don't really know at this
point how to go forward I think by we
you know what I want and this is my
honest opinion man I want the people to
just be like go [ __ ] yourself open up
those doors were going mean to what
America decide let up let the American
Society and I'm not seeing that just for
me I'm saying it cuz that's what I'm
gonna do
the minute baseball opens I'm gonna buy
a ticket alone to the station of the
[ __ ] come on I'm not gonna be like I
need six feet apart [ __ ] you I want
someone sitting right you don't worry
you're mad I'm gonna I five that
personal lick somebody's face
give me it bring it and for anybody who
has a problem with what we're saying um
please please say what Elan musk what
did he say cuz he looks at big numbers
because the average age of death in
America is something like 79 okay the
average age of death with Coronas 81
yeah for any of you people my parent my
dad's about to turn 80 I'm going to see
I'm gonna take actually a Cova test a
real one at the doctor's don't say a
real one well I'm gonna go but just it's
my father and my mother so I'm gonna be
around them they've been isolated and
I'm gonna go you know celebrate his 80th
birthday I get that 80 year olds are
vulnerable I love it to 80 year olds
more than you [ __ ] do so let me tell
me tell you gonna shut down the economy
feel I don't you neither does my dad
know either my mom and and at the end of
the day it we have to there is a smarter
way to do this and I would store on
record cuz you guys but I won't say I'm
against this shut down and I
been against it two weeks cool not three
months ago [ __ ] you're not around
so like a gay guy I think I think it's
become it is is doing more damage it is
doing far more damage where are the
numbers one in five kids are starving
because where are the numbers ISM so the
CDC was was and it's their job to think
of worst-case scenario I don't like
turns it's not their job to look I just
wish we get off the subject it's good
you know these facts are in this scene
and all these other places aren't
putting it out there these are bright
brightly make this up now I didn't make
this up Joe didn't make this up now you
are working to make this yeah and
unfortunately like I said to these guys
you're [ __ ] handle mine unfortunately
if you don't get involved in politics
politics will get involved with you and
this is a case of it and I'd love to be
able to try go to the beach right now I
can't do anything and this is where like
this is at this point at three months
and I know we're opening up but this one
I did I would say right now in this way
I got what I do at least my dad did to
me I don't know why you're crying we're
opening up yeah I want world but not
open up fast enough that I agree the the
fair in Americans is what bothers me
well I travel round the room has mass
gun yeah when I'm on my bike in the bike
ride puts his mask on
that's what Bob's means the fear and
still because of the media yes and
they're off man and they're straight up
[ __ ] that's right hmm no the
lockdowns mistake we know this yeah
these come out a few would disagree my
bill things should keep going a lot of
actors in Hollywood you know these
different networks have these actors
actors who have a lot of money who have
plenty of money and are living in their
mansions yeah saying home hash tag home
together you don't know what the [ __ ]
you don't know what you're talking about
what other percent you know you know and
I know people who are really in trouble
what's life like in Vegas compared cuz
California has to be the worst
California and Washington right now
watching just I think they're on state
of emergency till I think they pushed it
till June or July Wow yeah I wonder what
their what are their facts that they're
looking at that's making them stay till
June on the lockdown because I don't see
any of it that and that will keep me up
at night yeah I mean it's like well if I
have access to them and on muskers asset
so what is and yeah I know you've
watched the pot yeah I'm [ __ ] idiots
yeah why
what's that are you going up yeah that's
a good question
what are they going off of yeah and it
bothers many people that I'd like
postman like ken Jeong i-10 junction you
know this you know this my fate people
on earth when he tweets out that Coronas
10 times worse than the flu or what I'm
like [ __ ] Ken he's a matter of you
doctor
yes you know that's not true you [ __ ]
know that might be 10 times more worse
for people who have who are 81 who are
80 and who have underlying morbidities
that is maybe true the bottom line is
you have to target this quarantine you
cannot have a blank it's never been done
in the history of our country never been
done in the history of our country for a
virus that correct me if I'm wrong again
ninety-eight ninety-nine point nine
percent I mean I'm 20 percent other
people survived not acceptable i I it's
not acceptable well but we've been
through this before where when Woodstock
went on we had the things called the
Hong Kong virus and it was it killed a
million people killed like 70,000 in the
United States and they still did
Woodstock during that yeah we didn't
shut down the calm down I think it's
very like it's very uh fear driven right
especially when they only tell you the
celebrities that got it and then they
just leave that alone
Kevin Durant's got it oh my god
everyone's gonna die they haven't talked
about Kevin Durant is okay now oh never
talking about Rita Wilson is okay Tom
Tom Hanks is okay Utah Jazz yeah all the
whole dot it there are no they between
not like I'm so sick of this we feel
fine we're self corn by the way correct
me if I'm wrong aren't 70% of the cases
asymptomatic oh hold you have your about
the prison 98% were symptomatic a
symptom at a symptom s so they didn't
have any ninety-eight percent of this
prison god they got it and they didn't
know have symptoms and I've talked to
talk to plenty of people I've talked to
a total of six people not plenty of
people six people who have had it and
someone was a smoker it was from most of
them it was one I'm one of them Justin's
brother thought he had [ __ ] allergies
did the other thing yeah and we know
that obese people are mower yeah up sup
that'll be cats away from the door hmm
let's move on
sorry guys don't tweet us your facts and
all that cuz I have a million for your
ass don't do that you're not gonna win
it yeah don't send me anything from CNN
as well I'll tell you what's funny at
this it's hilarious to me we're doing a
fight painting that Saturday we gave me
and J overtime on this you Rogen and I
gave Eddie so much [ __ ] with the Flynn
case and the Russian probe and all that
yeah and we'd say he go it's fake news
and all this and walls lying there I was
like [ __ ] up we look I remember the
three of us young Eddie Bauers shut the
[ __ ] up and I tweeted all this to tax
all say go you know what totally I Louie
was laughing today yeah Eddie was right
he was right this whole time and he was
right I don't frustrate we are with
society not gimme stats they're not
Eddie I don't know I was like dude Rob
you shut up you don't know what you're
talkin the FBI who didn't want Trump to
be present at all costs and they
overstepped their bounds and they always
they implicated Oh baby baby basically
got Flynn to perjure himself yeah and
you were supporting mr. general three so
you guys were supporting the FBI yeah
Eddie called out oh this is all
distraction yeah it's all [ __ ] when
I feel bad I'm free [ __ ] I'm so I kept
poking I'm like any time what else that
time else and then I just want Brian and
Joe to go out and like yeah poking Eddie
and Eddie must have been so frustrating
I feel so bad because I I said I mean
the FBI is not standing or institution
yeah and it's done a lot of way more
good bad guy it's just that you you had
it you had a political there were people
in the FBI yeah at the upper echelon who
had a political agenda
dude how how how about those guys in is
it Venezuela those are kind of the
Blackwater boys that went out and got
caught I thought about this ya know you
you haven't seen this either
no James corner alright that's whatever
year old Jordan so whatever your old
Blackwater yeah but Blackwater boys
that's so of Blackwater well no they're
a virgin that will Blackwater meaning
they weren't supported by the US
government
Oh former
Rangers that decided trying to get the
Venezuela they got caught uh-huh and you
hear everything went wrong everything
went wrong with a guy cop even before
they have to shore do you hear what
President Trump said he was that
definitely wasn't us because we went
much different the guy was asserted
there literally everything went wrong
from me oh yeah like you're gonna go
take over a car but now they have the
two Green Berets and they can tell
they're under you know under stress
because they had a professional body
reader and yeah they keep like looking
up and looking around they have them
reading this stuff and then I turn to
distress man when you save those boys
here we go you know who's happy Eddie
Bravo look at these the guys are these
are the Blackwater guys ones why do they
all look like wash jets from hilarious
that's silver Corp that's right and
there's one mastermind behind it and
they got I guess they got caught before
they even got to the to the shore over
here yeah you we saw it from miles away
- you were dog paddling you had a strobe
light on sink you know what happened to
them did they they get arrested or do
they just kill another they got them
they they're the other in custody men
and out in you know it's yeah you can't
torture Americans dude yeah so yeah you
don't go to another country as a as he
privately contractor well that's the
funny for they were out there no they
were gonna try to assassinate Medora
what were they gonna try to do lead a
coup it they were gonna try to basically
lead a code get the guy who Maduro is a
bad dude but yeah let's really really do
them out of there it's really
interesting by now super interesting
yeah Magda Briscoe but that's the that's
the battle it's no longer
covin open up the economy yeah I Trump
seems open up the economy to cattleman
62 guys decided to go take over to help
overthrow the Maduro regime but it's not
supported by the government although you
send our real boys in it that it gets
fine we don't
that's how that works yeah America
hashtag America
Travers didn't hashtag America you know
I was uh I was in a the Philippines
right I just shown the Philippines and
then uh was a guy the Iranian general
that got assassinated the Jomon or
whatever so they want ceremony so um on
so that's all over the news
in the Philippines right and I'm
scheduled to play Dubai the next week
after that assassination and I'm telling
my manager I'm like I don't remember
they were making all the threats there
enough you're gonna do some dude is
gonna shoot some missiles over to Dubai
and my managers like just go home and
just go with believe me Dubai it's good
that's like--that's manager like what
are you taught are you not watching the
news we just killed the Iranian junk do
you know what Dubai is it's next door
right but you were fine we were no rabbi
nuts
Dubai was beautiful how many people is
it I played a coca-cola Rena can you not
look at the cameras as Mike here can you
not look like yeah yes but I don't know
their eyes that is that wine is that a
lot of people you can't was that a lot
of people huh is that low there look
look that's beautiful
can I say this though I'm walk-in down
the street we're doing like a commercial
right for a Dubai and two military
Black Hawks fly down the middle Black
Hawks is it called Black Hawks a
conscious black top black black hawk
yeah you really yeah which one's Mike
black coxster Black Hawk which one do I
have tagged black know what do I have -
black black okay cuz it's got to go far
too now not black hawk dude cuz I got a
lot of likes when I said black hashtag
black cop coca-cola Arena
yes coca-cola arena so check this out I
we're doing that advertisement right oh
I'm doing like it's like come to Dubai
you know is one of those things and
these two [ __ ] like whacked doc talks
with propellers on them yeah come right
down the middle man like low they're low
fly and they fly right over this we had
to stop it's just like you know so loud
bro all of our hearts were stopped
doesn't even drop some bro it just
happened we just killed the guy three
four days ago and here's my manager
Blake don't worry about her we're gonna
be good and these two Black Hawks come
right down man it was the scariest [ __ ]
and were they a patch it was bigger than
that no war he saw everything man you
saw the missiles yeah all that [ __ ] yeah
when I live by Santa Monica Airport yeah
Trump came in town for a fundraising
he's going to Beverly Hills and those
two I don't know why I've never seen
anything like it
no that's four it's four of those
helicopters were the engine it's their
plane oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
engines can go like this yeah when they
come in you're like holy it rattles the
houses yeah they're powerful and then
you see Air Force one landed like look
at that thing yeah I have come down on
you so hard they can shoot you with
Gatling guns and you don't see them
they're so far away so you don't hear or
see them oh there there are that word
you said that Reuters leaked a video a
war video that got out where these all
these dudes these Iraqi guys was
probably that's what it looked like
right there top left yeah top right
terrifying terrifying yeah look like
that yeah see those Gatling guns see
though that's a gallon everything they
shoot some crazy man they can shoot you
where you don't see them and these Iraq
you guys were all Congress they just
pulled off this thing they are they
ak-47s and you see all you see is the
ground just dust and they just all just
died there in a couple of seconds like
it was [ __ ] no that's what I would
buy if I was a billionaire I feel like
you buy one them kidney by that how much
are you just can't have it armed you buy
a helicopter no I want that's but how
cool that would be that's tough to land
on top of a roof with that you can't you
can't have it I then open it up and go
like this could I could I land it here
right
Kyle landed here I guess it seems kind
of heavy I'll go to another rooftop all
right but it seems kind of heavy
I'd all go to another rooftop what'd you
say I'll go I'll go to another rooftop
say black [ __ ]
it's my black ha ha [ __ ] out here I
guess so hey 5.9 mill wheel that's cheap
ten no deal joke please
did they tell you I got a Costco don't
the pave Hawks ten mil we're working it
to the black [ __ ] four four five point
nine five point nine boom hashtag get it
dude oh we get it you need the right
pilot though you know
rest in peace Kobe you need the right
pilot bro yeah those things are
effective the Apache I try helicopters
right right one Kobe pass way I want a
helicopter from from Burbank to the
break that traffic's terrible
yeah who's tough to find him it's tough
to find bring up the Apache helicopter
that's actually what you want
that's that Blackhawk is primarily a
transport chopper yep I see more chopper
yeah I saw one with a bat same kind of
[ __ ] I like that gray one is what I saw
if that's a that's what we saw yeah now
that's that's not that's a whole
different situation yeah baby I'm like a
giant wasp looks like a murder Hornet
yeah it looks like a murder Hornet and
it is a murder Hornet it'll do whatever
the [ __ ] it that's I took a picture
Rowling had a I thought he had a murder
Hornet boy a guy from tool it was
actually a tragic tragic trench a hawk
and I took the picture home except I
wasn't murder loss and then I was it
that's it China it's not a giant
oh well it's it's it's this big tariff
and though the warrior wasps were bigger
they that is a [ __ ] do you get those
there's everything here that from there
alive and well in Los Angeles Boulder
yes they are
no no Arizona and all over Vegas and I'm
all over with though but how about check
this out the warrior wasp oh do you know
where they were found the executioner
the warrior the warrior where did I go
China released the warrior wasp America
are you talking about that Queen Hornet
yeah no the warrior what the the murder
the murder murder law yeah so the
murderer enjoy that enjoy that that was
that flew and Dubai that hurt that's
what we saw that hurt
guns and big black [ __ ] we're gonna
size that you know badly that hurts you
know what that'll do to you does it kill
you nobody's gonna hurt you're our boy
coyote piercing at stumble they kill
tarantulas jo koy what now hold on they
what they do is they insert their eggs
in the trench 'la and then the babies
eat the transfers inside no holes right
there fun time that's what the but with
the murder wasp so here's what's funny
about that right it's all over the media
well there's been two in water Hornets
murder Hornets there's been two it in
Washington right one died the other one
they can't find Joe and one died god
damn it god damn it yeah cuz I'll say no
dude because I see rattlesnakes or
videos post rattlesnake yeah right if
murder Hornets start to come I'm
probably and quit bike riding and then
Jamie goes we'll have you seen them and
brought up the fact that there's two one
died the other one they can't find
that's hilarious in that funny oh my God
look at the hand there please are you
mind by the way can you bring up there
there there there there they live in the
ground and they'll come up and say I
live in the ground they live in what do
you people here your socks and they have
a neurotoxin ro and they can they'll
sting you several times I'm gonna
straight-up fistfight I love this and
they'll bite you and hold on you and
just [ __ ] little hump stinging yeah
there you go enjoy that and that beef
it's Japanese yeah John Award it yeah
okay what's last time somebody here got
stung by a wasp or Hornet been a hot
second for me okay my father-in-law got
stung by wasps like two days ago it was
hilarious
it didn't really hurt him but quietly
he's trying to show off for my grant in
friend's grandson there's a wasp and I
go let me just spray it with this at
home move away
there's no no I get I'm old school I
doing my hands make do with your hand
dude and they went to hit in the water
and I think that what are we doing dude
sit that hit him right in the claw sit
that like that hit it in the hand yeah
oh sure
he let me come
I wouldn't look like a yellow jersey
yellow you know the women have abs here
oh that oh no I'm just gonna hit it with
my hand I feel like it's better shut
your mouth this is old school was it was
it a mud wasps bring up a mud wasps now
he was yellow and black your standard
like yellow yellow jacket yeah you look
like the the Matt Allen right there
Georgia Tech yeah that's him oh yeah
real skinny vacuum that's a mud dauber
that's a mud dog you why would you smack
that he's trying to myself weapon - mud
dauber too much don't run trust me my
son smacking the knife he was gonna
smack him into the water the thing was
like I don't think so not today dude you
just don't throw your head you know what
time I mom was fixing a fan that was on
yeah cuz I lived in the Philippines and
she was fixing the fan cuz he was it was
it wouldn't uh she was trying to make it
taller and she was unscrewing the bottom
and it came down and she goes oh Jesus
Christ
gotta be careful I mean this isn't a
funny story I'm just lying on one up
your story right now my dad you don't
use your hand to swipe a wasp or catch a
fan or or you don't you don't you use
your left hand to unclog ice blower a
snowboard yeah dad dad raised a teenager
that's an idiot no he was young man hey
Oh young he's making money he was
blowing snow he got stuck yeah well I
got it unstuck it I got it put his hand
in there and the Machine went thanks bro
Oh laughter three fingers Salvage two
but old Tricky's not there anymore no
yeah you know when dad's like this how
old was he
like 17 a my son everytime seniors what
happen to your finger every time I don't
have to describe every time I uh
for the rest of his life he's pretty
cool the little nub I don't know but but
the the the middle finger is it's like
knuckle and there's just like scars
around it and then the pinky - I'm sorry
to call your daddy Tom that's all right
black belt
Marshall I should be fine so what's
wrong with this ice blower here no no
leave it on the problem crank it up to
high close to the blade that's a very
good very good for shop impersonation
from Texas hey hey thank you dude that's
sexy good your hey Joe you're a good act
you're a good actor you're still
breathing that's really see you're
holding right in it sounds wrong without
a nothing leave it on
hey boss there it is and then I'm the
neighbor thank you
you save his fingers I just feel your
flow I feel your fainted guys good job
that's thank you is not a breath you
there was a bit was like the best and
first nice to his dad I've ever seen her
ah thank you smoked a since you guys
were talking about it there's a video
going viral of a praying mantis eating a
murder Hornet face first face off yeah
now the video I saw Greg Fitzsimmons
posters and Rogen reposted it I mean it
takes a while yeah Jake's wild as well
what do you think he was just gonna
chomp it off yeah
hoping that sees that temp let's see the
size of his mouth that's an awful a
while that's all you know but he'd have
his head off first and the thing still
alive that's not all the time and this
[ __ ] poor murderer is doing his best
Oh Oh terrible rate is it terrible it's
a murder Hornet everybody that's true
Wow oh you mantas don't [ __ ] dude I
love praying man don't still still try
to sting still try stop trying so hard
if you have your spring stuff like hey
you trying to translate me huh he's
almost a murderer huh that's hilarious
hey I'm eating your thoughts are you
kidding me right now
a trained mantis is no [ __ ] [ __ ]
face/off I love him and Shaq it's so
fast - they're just like Ted Ted don't
the the females kill the the males after
have sex yeah rip their headphones yeah
manda brutal animal still have that
floating around then those Murray yeah
I'll take a prank you think about prayer
mantis is you can take them as pets can
oh cool then I can use our face I call
what else you got you have any pets got
a dog with your money do you want to buy
an exotic pet okay bye tiger no no be
Bobby Tolan - no exotic pets and they
just end up dead
what were they only wanted to say it now
you lizard mmm one that turns beard
color million and chameleons I owe those
myself yeah that one through tide that
one just turned white I'm leo
and they only have three fingers it's
not matching anything he looks cold so
what happened then the other one is the
the Hedgehog died yeah generic sonic
felt so bad
well we named him and then how do you
die it's not V no because the kids get
bored of it yeah kids get bored bored of
the hedgehogs and they stopped feeding
well hedgehogs
my son fast like the curtain my son's
been feeding his his bearded dragon
though pretty really cool that's cool
yeah I hope we don't get any hate mail
because of that we travel who hasn't had
kid oh that's him
you rub them the wrong way though you
know proms yeah yeah there are the rats
with spikes whatever is your headboard
they just do you know what kids do so
this was submitted by Jeff on Twitter I
can't pronounce his last name but he
wants Brendon to react to Canada
accidentally banding a black rifle
coffee company why because we're all
rifle ban they didn't know it was a
coffee company they saw black rifle and
they banned it they said today is coffee
at the end of that pink Justice black
rifle BRC 15b yeah and they think black
they think rifled they don't assume they
had that's best shooting in that
discussion so the people were killed
Jesus Christ I had a I was driving
around with an ak-47 or some kind of a
that's alright Justin Trudeau yeah he's
go ahead say it
go ahead go get your dick yet no no um
Canada can do whatever they want but he
tends to be super Pro shut down forever
but maybe I'm gonna lose it
mm-hmm I don't know ah that's just a
mistake I'm sure the BSA shot the black
rifle okay so this photo was posted on
to Reddit apparently a mom got bored and
put fake nails all her baby even notice
that was baby hands I thought there her
is tile tan that's kind of cute and
they're mad that they should put acrylic
nails on the baby yeah we don't know for
sure if it's actually glued on the way
chrome nails are or if it's on but a lot
of people are angry because one it's
unsanitary to have acrylic nails and to
the baby will scratch the hell out of
its face yeah yeah I assume the mom you
don't have to get really guilty right no
I used to and then I got them taken out
yeah I like the I like it when girls
have that kind of nail like I'm sure
it's just weird sexier and I think it's
cleaner like Alice
like the cows and we like the third
little dirt under yeah these women are
very concerned than they're rightfully
concerned I'm concerned this paper will
poke her eye out my mom did it was like
have fun yeah you know there are some
dumb people and yet were silly of course
there but we're assuming the mom isn't
responsive which is kind of silly I
think that was taken the picture was
taken and then the they were immediately
taken out that is dangerous though -
yeah I don't think she gave those things
bigger worries in the world in this
moment we all know that that baby would
probably swallow that nail so no mom's
not that Mommy moms aren't that stupid
hopefully but then also a five-year-old
steals a car to go buy a Lamborghini so
cute [ __ ] she's five do yeah yeah and
if it was on the highway but I wonder
the reason why I was bringing that up
about the nails okay yeah baby's hand I
just tell you why I think that is the
only way a woman should have their nails
is like her house endure because when
they do this because when they do that
they do that for a long time right you
have to wear your nails that long for
like two three weeks right yeah usually
I will you let me talk just one pocket
on there let your [ __ ] guests talk
I'm sorry doctor I was looking at that
you go thank you God Spyder sorry and
the cool no come on man okay when they
wear their nails that long
yes does anyone ever think when they
wipe their [ __ ] how do they hold the
toilet with your nails
no maybe you how do you hold the toilet
paper like this can hold it with your
finger Dennis brother nope no no every
time you take the toilet paper you wrap
around your whole entire hand that's how
they wipe their [ __ ] yes well that's
a problem that's your humble entire hand
it's covered in toilet paper and then
girls with long fingernails have to wrap
their hand and wipe their ass they're
using like I would say they're not
getting a good wife before you're not
gonna you know I will roll on one wife
yeah you're not getting a good wife
really you're doing that if you're doing
this where's it which one's my camera
this and you're wiping you're just
smearing it you need each individual
finger to really really wanna pew late
know why crannies I thought might shove
is really stuck and then on top of that
the acrylic nail kind of goes like ours
L so they spray you it's great now you
need you need water you need to go on
the shower next though gotta go jump in
the shower you got long nails keep it up
keep your watcher nurses have acrylic
nails yeah now we know we learned
something yeah well more you know I'll
come on man no I didn't for you know
that Mart
no don't smart right thank you what
you're always smarter than is a breeze I
can be taller imbecile it's called you
infants
oh yeah infants infants my favorite cuz
you're smart you uh you're a bit of a
fan favorite I'll give you that much
well I think the people like you cannot
massage the bottom of your thigh
whatever do that I pushed it yeah I
pushed and pulled away hey which was
like here okay no listen you're kind of
a hold a weighted slam salmon come on
where's my chapstick buddy everything
turns everything turns very southern hey
man hey man I ever tell you man we ever
tell you come on it's a family show dude
it's a family yeah you're so
disrespectful what else yeah did you
just I just covered your paint and your
[ __ ] what chapstick dude hold on
alright so this woman was having a
virtual visit with her boyfriend that's
in prison do you guys know about virtual
visits I didn't know you could do that
she's no I had no idea you like the
inmate yeah so on a phone or cell phone
or something like FaceTime yeah so she
was in her room and she was mastered
but she had a kid in the room too it was
like a 12 minute long video and then the
the phone or the computer she was using
you could see the guy also jacking off
and the kid was in the room I didn't see
the name of how old the kid was it was a
kid it was an infant
says we was like next to the bed walking
he was walking around to that the kid
was walking walking around near the bed
that's her boyfriend
talking guy he's got a real person he's
not he's not a real well I suppose
they're an entire new body while she's
doing this the boy seen standing next to
the bed and Wow so damn it she's charged
with a felony man yeah yeah they should
take the baby away go to Raleigh minutes
to 12 minutes a young boy just
dramatized and then walks we spray at
least at least two right
hey they remember everything man I
remember my son you know there's a
matter jay-z song at 4 years old and it
freaked me the [ __ ] out I'm not even
joking yeah [ __ ] I'm turning on the car
and my son was like why cuz I'm young
and I'm black and I'm white like 4 or 5
I was like yeah what oh yeah it fries
yeah he retained it and do it that so he
this kid sees this and remembers that
that's kind of bucket I guess foreign
Tiger understands a lot yeah man
people think oh you know the Drake
lyrics the working on the weekends like
yous yeah it's Creole Papa working on
the weekdays like you yeah so funny he's
like sitting there and he's he's the kid
is fearless when we take him to this we
take him to this parkour gym that's
empty and let him run around yeah and
you know Brandon will set a timer and
after the kid will run around for two
hours without stopping Disneyland and
and then hey okay hey bud we gotta go
and tire just goes everything I'll go
dude we got to go you set a timer papa
there has to be a timer
yeah a timer that's or battle dude we're
going to bed soon Papa set a timer oh I
hear five minutes man you better this is
my advice to you man enjoy highs moments
bro
my son is 17 at 100 teenage kids no I
was crying on the inside and it was just
like you know I wanted
a collage video and post it on Instagram
and I could have I start I would cry I
go I can't do it yeah a little like that
[ __ ] me and I was just like five years
ago I was like oh my god don't get at
something where he was 11 I'm like my my
other baby was five months and he's like
in that super cute stage I tell my girl
all the time such room in the thick of
it in the quarantine it's rough I'm like
we're gonna miss these day a bit when
these kids get older that's why I want a
bunch of kids yeah yeah that's a good
idea man do that why don't you get Jen
Brando Brando style oh one last thing on
this one of the detectives in the case
his name was asked man detective asked
man unfortunate is that true yes see
right here
contact detective ass man ASSA it's
unfortunate ask why detective ass man
all right this is just a can I say
something yes I used to work at a ticket
thing for Bellagio right and you take
the phone calls in and uh and you know
that they phone order right so I have to
take the name down to put on the thing
and you got to get the name I go excuse
me I go in your last name ma'am
she was new dick right and II you di ch
whatever is it would you look at it
doesn't look like whenever new dick okay
cool so she spells it out she goes it's
new day and I go and your first name
swear to god you guys she starts
laughing I go what he's laughing at she
goes I just want you to know I married
into this name it's not my last name and
I'm good I know you're gonna laugh but I
have to tell you I go what is it she
goes it's Anita I should just start to
write you I do the damn meadow
choice that's hilarious
that's alright dick this is from Robbie
Fox he saw this from Hulk Hogan he
posted his back and is just an
interesting looking back yeah that is a
weird bad right well he's probably a lot
of Surgeons yeah there's a lot of bats
oh yeah yeah oh my god that's a lot
that's a shame huge back though yeah
he's a big guy was he six hate or
something like that uh nope six three
the pain those guys perform it is gotta
be and who's always in heels he's
naturally the next ring
I've been next way he's in heels when
he's wrestling because six eight mmm Wow
me too he came to with my fights and
we're in the elevator gentlemen he's not
that big Wow Joe he says big platforms
up really I just got to work on his back
done yeah how him and Ric Flair's still
continue to wrestle is just like you
shouldn't have any excuse he's had crazy
work done that's whoever that surgeon
was was not good yeah well he's been
getting um since what 280 70s non-stop
back surgeries I love you a whole but it
looks like there's an [ __ ] on your
back yes yeah and I feel bad he's an old
man now how old is he
I'm looking find out yeah here's real
though 66 oh my god I thought he was
older I thought he was older too for
some reason I thought it was closer to
like 75 or something but he's only six
seven Bubba listen it's us oven yeah I
know this though Jimmy's death yeah not
huh Wow
build height six seven three hundred
pounds damn
oh hell next to it says show a picture
of him next to the rock that'll give us
a real understanding its how tall is a
rock 6-4 6-3 6-4 yeah
there there had a hey you're right your
IP look at that the rocks nowhere near
six seven yeah I'll try vanilla exactly
an elevator
soulful yeah wait so you're bigger than
Hulk taller know about the same sorry
not the same me and the rocker and what
wirless I I level and I look down his
shoes and he also had platforms on yeah
they're big boys though
oh yeah bad I loved the rock when he
wasn't so juiced why you know like you
know that's just that's his thing though
movie star that old it looks good looks
good no income baby get to veins your
skin looks different it tightens your
skin it's like whether you hold a skin
yeah I don't I really don't like that
right there I don't think I'm an 11 yeah
I think it just makes you look strained
it does a movie although he got big the
guy was on steroids
Hercules pain tendon I just don't think
this is where he went
really heavy well do you see him on the
left that's when he was in be cool and
he thought by getting into Hollywood he
thin out and then his agent like dude no
people aren't gonna hide for that be you
man and you know I think all right cool
me all big well we can't say that we
don't know if he did that oh yeah we do
I'll get Brennan I look at the friend
knows this stuff basically looks good
there I thought you meant animation for
some reason no no he was yeah he got big
for this role this is where he put on
all the pounds right here I wouldn't
look at that look at that picture I wear
the blue even before this for Scorpion
King he did as well I would imagine the
guy without steroids could look very big
right be oh yeah yeah he's already very
big and that's him in Scorpion King oh
that scorpion do you think he's always
been on juice like you see him at 16
he's jacked
yeah but dub either be a hundred percent
he was right oh yeah why wouldn't you
the bot the beating those boys take Joe
will you be watching the you see this
weekend yeah first first live I know I
don't lie but but you ain't I don't lie
you I like this you ain't yeah well the
reason I said that is because I
no there was a hey see what I mean I
don't think the world knew I knew when
he told me earlier that
ufc's coming back you slide to 4/9 paper
you ain't stacked yeah that's crazy but
how are people gonna react like you know
it's still gonna be great
you can watch UFC without sound and it's
amazing it's not as good though and how
about how is it gonna be without check
this Apple this is even worse for them
to do it Rogan is on one side of the
cage and it's on another and DC's not
nothing would let them sit and roll the
dice but we're all healthy who gives a
[ __ ] let us all together and they're
like no it's so ridiculous all yet of
headphones on the respond off each other
that start sucks but yeah I'll take it
I could do no coming tonight just didn't
give you my knives like we forgot I need
them too
I want my knives man dude yes Jam bomb
I'm a [ __ ] trail and there's coyotes
I saw three coyotes I didn't give a [ __ ]
does pack a box playing the phone calls
UFC fights the way Rogan does man DC and
Anika the bet that when the three of
them get together they're so good yes
Rowan's got him he's good what is the
greatest combat sports analyst I think
you've never been any sport needn't call
it football my bill applause that's what
might be tough yeah he just he's really
good yeah but I mean you still like if
you learned or like you know I mean like
you know like Steve and I smell sorry
you're the one that's talking about
giving him knives you got me at night
whatever the [ __ ] it get this [ __ ]
leather shoes I made of leather shoes at
a craft
it's just favorite colonel being a dick
how did you get that shirt no it's not
good cut it out cut it out hey did wrong
and get the elk jerky that jerky I gotta
form on a road that shot me dude
with our legit Montana damn it Joe I
swear to God I didn't do it though I'm
Ryan
now I'm like that super Asian right yeah
real agent this is Brian as a Japanese
man [ __ ] super stereo difficult
that's Bobby
that's Bobby lien doing hey you gonna
have to put subtitles on it cuz I'm not
gonna move my lips today you go that's a
fairy oh but you like it inside huh yeah
you're laughing inside I am you know
broke into another sports is like Steve
Naismith coming over to MMA unless
you're like a real insider people
[ __ ] hate it Steve Naismith in MMA
mmm I'm seeing is it's like it's like a
ruined Dennis Miller try doing Monday
Night Football
yeah but okay but I will say this though
like he's what I'm trying to say is he's
got the voice it's like uh what's his
name uh basketball guy uh where we got
caught wearing the the girls Bob Costas
no no the guy Marv Albert like that
voice man like it's just something about
that voice is great for him in the UFC
though huh I don't want to hear him
break down the UFC
yeah but I think I think Brogan's got
that voice man where you get yeah oh
yeah we want [ __ ]
you god I made him stay safe in China oh
look at this
this poor girl sits a girl inside that
suit she was wearing a stormtrooper
outfit look what they just dealt with I
know that's that's the timing was
terrible but you know May 4th is a big
Star Wars holiday right may the 4th be
with you yeah
so they've for the restaurant she had to
dress up like this to get more customers
to come in and then the cops obviously
got a lot of calls that someone help was
dressed as a storm trooper and had a gun
it's a plastic gun and then they took
her down right here the problem is too
cos she's old enough to know better I
mean the restaurant wanted her to do
this too
she playing music I think the car drive
by well that's it just still not that's
real because I know you see the cops
pulling up all right starts crying she
does cry yeah and the problem is the
suit you're not able to get down so the
telling her to get down you'll really
see in the video she can't you can't get
down cuz they champion her knees ok
[ __ ] idiot I know that's you're a
[ __ ] idiot this is what I do I always
sympathize with the cops that really
matter looks like the owner Priscilla
Brian Brian one of the purse only
sympathize it's like great job they did
their job that could have gone so ugly
that could have been that's exactly how
I say I would do it and I don't give a
[ __ ] after the fact all right after the
fact we found out that it was an airsoft
gun or it was a painted water gun try
being a cop and pulling up to somebody
that's walking around with a black gun
store trip no there was drugs ha scared
they are and after dealing with the
[ __ ] recent she is completely
acceptable how about that ones like you
do a shot jogging you find the video
online so but he had a history no it was
oh you talking about that the one that's
they think the huge and always right now
yeah so I do have it up it's no not the
video but we're not showing the murder
I'm [ __ ] awful there's a bunch of
stuff here so he was apparently an avid
jogger alright he lived in the area and
then this particular day he was jogging
yeah multiple people called 911 because
they saw someone running fast there's a
burglar in the area there's two
burglaries in the area if someone stole
a gun out of a car and stole $2,500
worth of fishing equipment that wasn't
reported okay
but then so yeah was it on him when he
was running did you see this guy looked
like he was jogging
what these two guys did was [ __ ]
awful they were hot two guys they caught
him oh yes so they got him they're in
jail right now
they weren't nothing happened in before
because of the law right it's like stand
your ground also like citizen's arrest
so they didn't do anything
and then I guess one of the prosecutors
at the time said like no they had a
reason to do this and then they recuse
himself afterwards and it wasn't until
social media and public outcry that
people
started like counting these people and
now they're arrested yeah arrested and
they did go into hiding but that first
it no one said anything and these are
the two guys following yeah yeah where
was Georgia okay so the kid also he's
like 25 or 26 year old he was there
saying that he was looking into a house
that was like under construction so he
was just kind of peeking through and
then they said that there were robbers
before so they figured this was the guy
800 - 800 mysteriously hunted him down
the video the video is awful they're in
the truck and they're enemies like and
they pull shotgun him and he goes what
the [ __ ] he goes move the truck in the
Shuman the chest he takes out front they
shoot him in the back well they should
be in jail for murder
what do you do if someone's gonna run up
with you with guns your horses they
should be put in jail for murder he's
got a history with that guy so he knew
him I don't think they had a history but
so they look back at his records and
it's there were rumors that he had
mental illness it's just rumors and then
when he was like kid there's reports
that he brought a gun to school and then
he had like did it shoplifting thing now
here's what it is these guys are racist
no of course there is a poster for sure
if [ __ ] racist [ __ ] it's not even
though I aim to kill all the police call
the police don't they were just dying to
do it and be heroes [ __ ] them [ __ ] those
guys just scum of the earth and then you
you also with a gun you hold him if you
think it says yeah you hold or when you
shoot him in the following list it's
such a disaster well it's a [ __ ] ball
faster that said that's you guys it's
all that video just babysit couldn't
wait to kill a black guy whose fault you
[ __ ] up he's been free since February
23rd minutes and it happened video
leaked this week that was mounting
pressure from them to be arrested
think about her his parents the GBI
officially took over the case Thursday
from local cops and Brunswick Georgia
that's why you have the hockey video
shows a mod jogging down the street when
he was stopped and confronted by
McMichaels
a brief struggle between Travis and
Ahmad nice before the gunfire
Ahmad fell to the ground well deaf I
don't want to see that you've seen okay
I hate I stumbled upon it
that's how I said no I thought there was
your [ __ ] day it did it ruin your day
it's almost guys things should lead
actor
yes object man put him in general pop
baby there were allegations of
corruption because the elder McMichael
used to be an investigator for the Glynn
County yeah
after the video came out the DA formally
asked the GBI to investigate now two and
a half month old case these guys are
free for travel yeah they shot a dude in
the back unarmed yeah jogging cool hey
thanks Georgia and local local cops
they're like what are you doing guys
what are you [ __ ] doing I'm sorry
there were free till people up to the
yeah grant society though everyone was
remedial saying I got this is where this
where I like social media right now that
you don't thinking positive yeah another
man summer no let's just do get more
Corona facts give some positive how
about those old picture of right
Guy Fieri help recently million huh I'm
gonna flavortown yeah yeah 20 mil for
Russian workers wait flavortown good for
a good for guy right I live that guy in
like two months I think it was yeah less
than two months good for him an employee
relief fun yeah he reached out to
everyone like Pepsi coke all the good
[ __ ] guy yeah sure one more
combat-related sure I like combat like
like fighting a retired on fighting
combat I don't know how you feel about
this but Mike Tyson was offered 20
million by bare-knuckle fighting
championship how about the owner tweeted
out that he already signed it was gonna
sign Michael type Mike Michael Mike
Tyson for Shannon Briggs bare-knuckle
and I was like oh [ __ ] I to it out if
this is true this is insane but then
they they don't have them son nope
that's Mike they think was a guaranteed
offer that's it it's an offer although
20 million dollars is a lot of its way
around I'm like for Mike I don't think
is that much money bubble oh now he's
killing all not even close now it's the
weed business he's young I know
right has no clue about anything oh hey
so Mike Tyson is a huge marijuana
business I didn't know that because you
don't know things well hold on wait
accuse doesn't know things wait he likes
to act like oh wait no he has mystery if
world wars no wait wait he's here if he
knows a lot of being relevant don't want
to know I love things well yeah what is
that how do you know his business is
doing really well though as weed
business because I know I've talked to
him I know I'm in CBD he's in marijuana
I know how much we make I know how much
he makes and he owns all of it yeah I
know it makes millions and millions upon
that a million dollars she wouldn't do
it
younger 21 million dollars though just
to fight again a million oh I thought
was twenty million dollars a million no
20 million Oh million which is a good
chunk of cash I thought no no not a
milot axis 500 I'm talking about 20 mil
20 mils good amount of money
you got it you got anybody's attention
to anybody play mil good you're doing it
yes 100 percent sound do your training
and you're doing Mike that says more
money than me I think
sure but 20 million dollars is up after
taxes Joe yeah you know it's ten no my
testing is doing me won't you check
you'd wax your [ __ ] bunghole
I mean does a mil I thought you arguing
no I'm more I'm already in 20 men one
he's a good good alright one I mean
that's a lot I went to a Tyson fight you
guys thank you for that all right
biggest in Vegas back in the day back in
when you worked in there yep those used
to be a royal craziest things I ever
seen man you've been a UFC fight oh yeah
I we doin oh I used to go to all of them
way back today I saw a voice fight Matt
you know like a big big boy fight like a
Connor or like and they Anderson Silva
was the instance I used to go back in
the day day to land I said hoist Gracie
but what holy spot Matt that was a huge
fight when he pretty soon he ever took
the gear off you know that was an
amazing fight uh I saw I got to meet
Sakuraba that was awesome one of the
greatest moments of my life so I said I
got a picture with Andy's hey won't you
show
I'm just asking would you shut your face
man I'm just asking a question
bro I don't want in trouble I'm sorry I
uh I uh yeah I love you of UFC fights I
love them it's just not the same feel as
the boxing's not the same as UFC on such
a better show no I said I love you I
know I'm just saying it's such a better
show like a big pay-per-view UFC
embarrassin is unbelievable yeah the
last UFC was a TJ Dillashaw I lost it
all when he lost to a suit oh yeah you
went there yeah I was there nice yeah I
bet it's Vegas you always there no that
was in New York okay well he J looks
better that was cool that's cool he's
great yeah he's a great time Adam can
you show did you finally gave him some
of your merch
yeah TJ's great man he's great yeah
shoutouts to TJ ah well this has been
really fun I'm gonna go shooting now wow
this is how you end it that's okay
that's how you end it yeah it's Friday
is it Friday Wow except for tomorrow
Friday okay it's Friday tomorrow action
feels exciting this is a big UFC
pay-per-view yeah but when you I'm sorry
I'm just gonna do some real quick yeah
you ever say hey let's look at an old
picture of somebody and that little
picture is a young picture of somebody
but when you go hey can we see an old
picture of Ryan and you look at an old
picture of Ryan and it's it's just him
fold no man what do you do no no I mean
like let's see an old picture we put
when you post that trailer oh my god oh
my god so suppose that movie I want to
get my clown you still bad by that
probably friend member when I'm Lisa I
remember when I did I did I was in China
and I was Norland doing that movie yes
by the way my psoriasis was like I was
just covered in psoriasis sure it was so
hot I was so miserable but it's my dear
friend Gill and he did a children's
movie it's a kids movie about a talking
dog with Megan Fox and Josh from a good
movie for kids a great family movie
so he goes will you post my trailer I go
of course you're my boy I'll do it
I didn't realize that wasn't in the
trailer so I made all yeah a little our
fans watch a [ __ ] trailer
so bad they're all [ __ ] older it was
so bad that wasn't in it
I thought Bryan's older I've got roses
they go the people were like you know
I've never read comics I read every
comment um so funny that Chris cousin
guy yeah you play the steaming pile of
dog [ __ ] this I mean they they were
all there were so many funny [ __ ]
texts they were just like so fun they're
like hey Joker hey Chris goes you played
the first Asian guy this guy goes
is this another I'm in the Joker movie
thing guys sorry I made you watch that I
had no idea
now watch this by the way this might
have hurt my friends movie because
everybody's like get out of here here
here I am say that's really sorry yeah
hey guys I guess I posted that I made
you guys watch that hey I want a
positive resent crisco's I want it to be
clear you post that didn't make one and
I mean one person wants to go see that
movie I wish you and the person you
asked you to post that understand how
the goddamn then it got so bad that my
friends were calling about dude jeez you
got to take this down like I've never
taken it down I deserve it I should look
at what I'm posting before I post it I'm
just like he's my friend of course I'll
do it you know you do favors for I did I
actually hurt his movie oh I will never
see that movie I don't want to hate the
movie already took Chris's point the guy
who asked you to post the trailer and
you post it no one's gonna see it yeah
yeah because it's so frustrating that
sucks Brian you ruined a whole movie oh
come on please Joe honey they put into
that and it is it animated its Lionsgate
no no what is it it's not having seen
the trailer oh that's awful so much
money put into that and you [ __ ] come
on yeah one day earlier you played that
first like a dog that's so you're an
awful person
no come on where the movie dude
friends name kill younger oh he hates
you I apologize Gil he directed 10
Things I Hate About You oh he and now
it's 11 11 things 11 so you think you
you've shat on me this whole podcast
I don't absolutely not you shat on
yourself oh man yeah
come on run your stroke um shooting with
me right now I would love it man and I'm
being serious please come to Vegas oh
well you promise I promise you can I
promote one thing yeah yeah I do you do
I've spoken into June we got we got
Houston improv improbable copy 29 in
Primal first what was your thing Joe
Netflix you know this was always this
like I always had this thing that I
wanted to do and it's kind of like me
paying homage to my mom and I brought
Netflix to the Philippines and
everything about it is Filipino you make
us cry before release but I wanted to do
that for my mom like I brought Netflix
they're the whole camera crew was
Filipino all the off-site location stuff
was Filipino
Matty was Filipino not one like that no
completely yeah yeah but uh yeah and
what I wanted to do is bring Filipinos
that lived in America that's never seen
the Philippines they they hold it there
Americans you know I mean yeah and uh
and I wanted them to see what their
parents sacrifice so that they could
have a beautiful life in America there
and well I brought them so that comes
out June Oh it'll be on Netflix it's
called Brian Posehn yeah I want people
to watch it you don't mind don't want
people in the Philippines not to watch
it because of Brian
Brian's actually from there he's been
there his point he's born there her
supporting him in that money you still
don't want to posting yeah I don't want
Our Lady of Lourdes Hospital I believe
Wow you can't come so he says I love you
more so yeah it comes out June it'll be
on Netflix called jo koy in his element
tonight and it's pretty cool man we we
you don't so we brought Filipinos and we
brought Filipinos that live there it
gave them a shot to perform in front of
Netflix and there's the President of the
Philippines no you are yes he does
everyone does come on take it easy have
you met Duterte I don't know if you know
this what what about I don't know if you
know this but a police escort everywhere
what about many paths around like god
damn it Joe what about you and Manny
Pacquiao yeah I'm just I'm just saying
there's only like three of you there you
know you know I'm saying don't you say
man you get it
June money if I count your bars Bruno
Mars yes he's what do you talk about
Filipinos yeah don't you ever disrespect
us everything else go Chad Hugo
Neptune's hello every song from the 90s
was written by him he like Justin
Timberlake Thank You Jenny long time oh
really how about Rihanna lemon I don't
know let's see let's keep going
Neptune's knobs and all I'm saying
police escort they'll keep going though
oh [ __ ] you yeah don't [ __ ] you know
what I do up for my insecurity but you
guys really just June I think we're
gonna say June 12 yeah it'll be June boy
in his own juice Joe in his element
Netflix fake boy by club merch has
dropped this morn at 10:00 a.m. that
[ __ ] is a-boomin go to tea fat gay calm
or thick boy calm and get your gear
right now get it Brian anything yeah
Houston Houston I'll see you what me and
Brennan and shark eye style smile we'll
see you may 29 2013 34 movie there
anything improper you let's come out and
support it'd be fun yeah I got you I'm
splitting the money with you dude oh I
am I promise I am for real you know how
it's a it's a joint I do it with a lot
of give a [ __ ] I'm giving you after my
all right and I will see your money
I'll see you it's pecans hey can you do
me a favor yeah for the Houston improv
I'm gonna give you a thousand dollars
okay I don't want you to give it to the
staff oh [ __ ] your ass
percent I love that improv done I love
that management there they've been with
me since Jump Street when when it used
to be the rainforest cafe okay and and I
love them and I want to support all the
improv workers it's not you want to
match a lot of money I'll match it no we
got to good
alright that's awesome purse to shot
he'd been out of a hundred percent I'll
give him a thousand well that's three
great I got no problem giving all them I
wish actually talk about making
something I realize I know I know but
hey daddy leaves the house is not for
federal you're right you know that
you're right I'm a hundred percent
I'm not for free and people they need
the money they [ __ ] yeah they know
you're paying well we'll make sure it
gets to them you guys have been mommy no
for real
big boy bike ranch get it you don't give
my [ __ ] money
I come back with bullets no another
handgun no the money is gonna be taxed
obviously there's a food tax yes travel
travel tax we are your mules that take
the rest of that money I give it to that
shipping handling this is what you're
gonna do bucko listen to me
what you're not gonna tax anything
you're gonna eat the [ __ ] tag yeah
you're gonna give completely one
thousand dollars for my stuff yes and
you're gonna eat the tack call them
[ __ ] you're gonna actually pay more
what's called fun what and you're also
gonna [ __ ] eat history yeah what [ __ ]
oh but you do yeah you're gonna give
back to the people that gave to you yes
you [ __ ] oh they didn't even watch you
at the Houston Improv know what I
remember talking to management and
they're like Brian's coming again oh my
god
when did you talk to them they said I
know they said to only let him in if I
go there's not heard that [ __ ] guys
we're gonna do it this time it's gonna
be amazing
you know this time it's gonna be amazing
Brendon you're the only non-asian that's
wrong crap hold down with white
Philippines can you play can you play
our out song is bad but by Apple to app
Babs all the VEB ot that's our side you
come sure is a game in style
no damn a play play play this is our
outro the Philippines go baby birds no
you got a passport it got a passport it
just a little bit ok kept password
that's where hurry up right here right
here right say Philippines go thanks for
having me on your show you guys and
gentlemen this is the fight of the kid
with the koi we're out